Welcome everybody to another zoom call
Remember everybody comes in muted if you want to speak in a question you can certainly unmute yourself
To ask a question otherwise use the chat
Let's type in your question, whichever is easier for you. We'll get to the questions that
We're sent in first
I
Feel free to chat in a question reminder of anything that's new. We'll be up on the members site
And you can always self-schedule calls as well
So first question. I do I still take the powder and
Smoothie when I'm not taking the fanbend
So I think this person had a recommendation that they're on
the fanbed four days three days off or something like that
But they're also taking a smoothie with some other things and a pay me some spectra to work maybe trades first
So the answer is yes, you still take the smoothie the powder the other things the other days
You just don't put the fan bed is all product in it. You only put the fanbed is all product in it
The recommended days
So whether it's four days or three days whatever you just you do the rest of them on
All you do all of it for three days and then you do all but the fanbed is all for the other day
Yes, that's the correct answer
Next question. Is there an advantage to using a cold pack or hot pack on a tumour mass
Thinking about hot and cold therapy
Yes, there can be so well partly it depends on where the tumour mass is if the tumour is in your colon
You know or in your intestinal tract
Use not that the heat is not going to go deep enough the cold is not going to go deep enough
So remember a pack or cold pack is probably only going to penetrate
You know, maybe a centimeter
So if your mass is close to the surface
Absolutely and
So then you go, okay, what should I use heat or cold there can be benefit to using
Alternating like put hot on for five minutes then cold on for five minutes and hot on for five minutes
You can get a beneficial
Pumpied action of the limp around the tumour you could get a
the benefit of cryotherapy ice therapy or
hyperthermia
So there could be benefits to that too because both
Cryotherapy cold therapy can kill a cancer can kill the cells in a tumour and so can heat
So what should I do? Well do both you know, so you could do that pumping action five minutes on five minutes off
Or you could do I'm going to do heat today and cold tomorrow
Play with those and see if you get a response
There's nothing wrong with doing that is if the tumour is close to the surface
Again, if the tumour is pretty deep the chance of you affecting the tumour is pretty slim
um, you know, if you have it close to the surface then you have the ability to do some of those things. Yes
How long can mycotoxins stay in your system? Well
Remember mycotoxins are toxins from mold. They're not the mold itself
So it's not a limited organism and it probably has those those poisons have probably have a half life of
15 million years
So they can stay in your system as long as you don't detoxify that remember any toxins
Then you can measure in your system are
Things that you're you know, you are trying to get rid of
So when you do a urine test, you're you're getting rid of those things
Um, that means you have them in you to get rid of them your body is constantly detox
Try to detoxify if you're not detoxifying you're going to be dead at a very short period of time
You have to be able to detoxify
So uh, the true well, then why do I have these I'm not detoxifying. Well, you have them because you were either exposed to more than you could detoxify at any given time
Or um, you're just detoxifying more slowly you are detoxifying. So there's nobody that's not detoxifying
Um, remember the level of toxicity in your system is equal to the level of exposure of said toxins minus your ability to get rid of them
So there's times that were hyper exposed to things
And there's times that our liver is compromised and we're just not able to get rid of
You know, uh, a I don't say a normal amount, but because none of these things are normal. So um, but maybe the amount that we couldn't gotten rid of last week
Our stress level is up. So our liver is compromised
Remember stress is going to affect our liver's ability to detoxify because stress increases your sympathetic nervous system
And it's going to decrease your liver detoxification function
Remember the neurology of liver detoxification is tied to the parasympathetic nervous system
So one other thing you can think of to help detoxify
Yeah, just had a chat with somebody today about um toxins in their system and
they are on
Into a rejection drug so they can't take a lot of keylators
Because they could be keylating out the medication that they're taking so they have to be careful with that so then you can
So then you have to get a little bit more creative which all of us should be doing
One of the ways that you can help with liver detoxification pathways without changing body chemistry
By adding a supplement or something is to support the parasympathetic system
So there is a blog post if you go back to our website
I actually have this video on
Multiple places on our member site too. I just can't remember off the top my head
But if you go back to our website you just do the search bar and you search
Or parasympathetic
You will you will see that there is um
um a
uh blog post in a video on how to stimulate your parasympathetic nervous system and on that blog post
There's a downloadable pdf where you can there's a bunch of different exercises you could do functional neurology exercise
You could do to help stimulate your parasympathetics. There's also a pdf on some different functional neurology exercise
You can do to calm the sympathetic so watch the video that will help explain that
um
How to stimulate your sympathetic how to stimulate your parasympathetics and calm your sympathetic and
um that will go a long way with helping stimulated immune response helping to stimulate detoxification pathways
Helped to calm your heart very good for your heart very good for your brain decrease anxiety etc etc
So we live in a sympathetic driven world you have a scary diagnosis
It's going to stimulate your sympathetic nervous system. It's going to cause anxiety. It's going to cause depression
You want to stimulate your parasympathetics as much as possible
So go to that post you'll get a lot of little hints and if you download that that pdf
It's some seemingly silly things you could do that will stimulate the neurology
So it's all about stimulating that neurologic path of the vagal nerve cranial nerve 10
And then call me the part of the brain called the messencephalon
Which is responsible for stimulating your sympathetic so there's a need for sympathetic toe you want a balance of this
When you know a lion jumps out in front of you and you have to fight that lion or run away
You need a healthy sympathetic nervous system
But we live in a world where there's constantly lions were constantly putting out fires were constantly running away from
Issues in our mind. So even anything that is a perceived lion in our life is going to stimulate our sympathetic
So we have to be actively trying to stimulate the parasympathetic nervous system
Long answer to how long can Michael toxins stay in our system
But to honest answer is they'll stay in our system until we get rid of them any toxins that you're exposed to that you absorb
That circulate into your bloodstream are going to stay in you until you get rid of them
Again, your level of toxicity at any given moment is equal to
The level of exposure
Minus your ability to get rid of them
So if you show high on that toxic tech tester you show high on glyphosate tester you show high on a Michael toxic test
You're just not getting rid of these things
So you need to aid your body as best you can because these things get inside cells and they cause
All sorts of problems cancer is one of them
But it gets inside your brain it causes inflammation it causes microglial priming
It leads to Alzheimer's early dementia
It leads to Parkinson's it leads to all sorts of problems. So
Make sure that you stay focused on your purposes to detoxify
You only recommend in one product for both my Michael toxins and my other toxins. Why only one thing
Because usually I've already put you on things to help with your liver
And I'm hoping that you do the other things that I just spoke about in that last question about dealing with
Stimulating your parasympathetics and calming your sympathetic
And many times you know the products that are out there are not going to be
There's no products that are going to be specific to
X toxin
Um, I am benzene toxicity
So what's the anti benzene product that I'm going to take well there isn't an anti benzene product
There's something that's going to key late benzene out of your system
It's also going to key late Michael toxins and key late other toxins and key late heavy metals
So um, they're not even though they might have fancy names on the product like Michael poll
You know, what's a Michael poll for it's to pull Michael toxins out of your body
Well, yeah, but it's really ingredients. These that that will help pull heavy metals that will help pull
Poisons and benzene and other toxins on the toxicity tech test and
It
Nutritional companies have to give it a name in order to
You know appeal to a people group that are looking for such product
um
So but in truth, you know, that well, it's not going to be only specific to one thing
Secondly, I don't want to put people on you know 10 different things that
um
That you're you're going to have supplement burdo with just with the just supporting detox pathways and thirdly
I don't we don't want to detox so fast if you're going to
Use a key later you're pulling stuff out of the tissue. It's still has to go through the liver
So go back to the seven phases of detoxification
Information that you have available to you
With the seven phases of detoxification course is you have to be doing everything to be supporting phase six
Which is dumping into the toilet making sure that you're having adequate daily bowel movements
Phase five that you're binding things. That's why what I typically recommend something
It's going to be a binder plus a key later. So you're binding things in the
Larger tests that you're not reabsorbing the stuff that you're liver is putting trying to get rid of
um and then phase
For is that you're making adequate bile that really has to do with the parasympathetic nervous system and that's where
Excuse me coffee in them as in hot packs over the liver can help decrease the viscosity of your bile to get bile flow
So that you're able to get rid of these things remember all your toxins from phase one and phase two in the liver are then
Bound with phase three the production of bile which then is all of those toxins go through bile
Via encased in bile
Into the gall bladder and then into the duodenum
Then you have to get it into the toilet. So phase one two three four five six is so essential
In order for you to get rid of things and if you're going to put too much stress on phase zero
Which is key lady to doubt of the tissue
It's going to your grabbing too much out of the tissue too fast. It's going into the liver and the liver is like
Hey, settle down here, you know, you're in dumped home on shit here. I can't take anymore
And all you're going to be doing is transporting this through the blood and dumping it into some other
um
A tissue area which so you have to key late slowly
And you have to be making sure you're supporting phase one through six
Before you pull too much out on phase zero um and too much for your liver to handle
When should I be doing the day programs?
I think this is on the rife. What should I be doing the day programs on the rife and what order should I do them
So the day programs are you know, we have some people that don't do the day programs at all
I just made some shorter programs for your cancer on there um and uh and
There's no order to them. I just had to number them. Okay, so just so keep them in somewhat of an order
But there's no chronological order. I don't have to do number one first number two
And I tried to make them a little bit different length of time
So that you could recognize. Oh number two is a two hour one number one is a hour ten minute one
So I only have an hour and ten minutes and I'm going to sit and watch the show or something. So I'll do number one
Um, so no and some people don't do it at all
But I think you're better off getting as much rife time as humanly possible
So that's why I created those
Why is honey okay? So is honey okay to use as a sweeter?
Um
Well, it's better than using sugar. So why is honey better than sugar? Well, there's lots of reasons. So honey can self
has
Qualities that could be beneficial for your immune system
honey has qualities
That are that are much lower glycemic index we need it won't break down into glucose nearly as fast as other things
honey is
has uh
You could go into a lot of beneficial qualities of honey that it can be actually good for us
So um, um, now I'm not again, you you still have cancer and it's still ultimately going to be broken down into glucose
So if you're on a ketogenic diet, well then honey is out of the question
But if you're not on a ketogenic diet and you want a sweetener for something honey is probably your best choice of sweetener
Um, because of those other beneficial qualities
But again
Remember too much of a good thing. It's bad thing too. So it's all about balance
You certainly don't want to be just spiking your glucose by you to tell the honey thinking that that's good no
So I'm just going to hold you on that
So ultimately what breaks down to the glucose can feed cancer so because that you know
Cancer cells rely on glycolysis and the end point of glycolysis for
Um, metabolism so you have to be careful with it. So all about balance
How long does the iron pro wave last before needing to be replaced? So the iron pro wave
Is the foot bath apparatus for the true right? So you don't have a true right ignore the answer to this
I am pro wave foot bath apparatus for the true right
Last about 40 to 60 sessions before it needs to be replaced
But it partly depends on how you use it. So if you're using it
Uh, you know
Few times a week three four times a week. It's going to last 40 to 50 sessions as long as you're cleaning it correctly
according to
Your instructions that you that came with your right system
Um, if you don't clean it correctly, it's going to last a little less now
Honestly, we've had people that say oh lines lasted 60 sessions and I've never cleaned it once
partly depends on your water
So remember you are putting your tap water in the bucket you're putting your unit in there and you're adding salt
Um, so if you have you know high calcium in your water if you have
I mid or high iron content if you're all sorts of things can change that I don't know how chlorine and fluoride
You know act on the iron pro wave unit either so I'm not sure that causes more detrimental effects
Also, if you only use it like once every three weeks
It's going to probably last less time
Because you're using it. I mean less number of sessions maybe more time
But it's going to less number of sessions because you're using it and then it's it because
The it does corrode, you know, unless you completely took it apart and drive the whole thing after each one
Which is nonsense nobody's going to do that
But so it's going to corrode with the water sitting on it dry that's going to be
A lot of the corrosion
If you have issues with your iron pro wave you have to contact
True rife because we don't service those
Anymore and we don't even sell those anymore because we don't get any discount on it
It's just cheaper for you to buy it from true rife
Um, and then if you have issues that they're going to be more apt to be able to replace it
Because they have the final say in their product. So
Contact true rife if you have issues with it, but most people don't have too many issues with their iron pro wave
Um, what does it mean when my AST is elevated? So AST is an enzyme
Most it's in the comprehensive metabolic profile. That's what you're going to see it or
Anytime people will just get a liver panel done at their medical doctor
Um, and AST, ALT
Um, and alkaline phosphatase are considered the liver enzymes, but in truth
Those enzymes are in other tissues too. So
AST is going to be produced in more highly metabolic
tissues
Your muscles make AST
Your liver, obviously your heart your kidneys your lungs
Um, when would you have low AST?
Typically that's a
Vitamin B6 deficiency, so we don't see that very much
So
Most people you know, you don't have to be taking vitamin B complex or something like that to begin in your bees
If you're eating vegetables even good meat, you're still getting your B vitamins
So you're not going to end up with some
Gross vitamin B6 deficiency, but it does happen some people have really bad gut absorption
Sites for your B vitamins some people's diet has been really poor and they can't end up with vitamin B6 deficiency
It can be a vitamin B6idemia is a real thing. It's just not real common
Most of the time you're looking at elevations of AST. That's what this question is
So obviously the first thing you think of is liver. So
When AST and ALT are elevated together, especially with alkaline phosphatase, the first thing you're going to think of is liver stress
But in truth, it's not always the liver
You could have AST elevated with early congestive heart failure
So again, remember any blood test is a clue
And it's a clue that should get your doctor to ask other questions
You know, and I'm trying to get you guys to think like a doctor here. So I have elevated AST. What does that mean?
Could be my liver is got issues. So there's other things you'd look at too in conjunction with that
Again, like as my ALT and alkaline phosphatase also elevated well that it's more probable that
It's my it's my liver if my
GGT which is another test is elevated then I would think that it's maybe outside of the liver
um, if uh, so again AST can be elevated with congestive heart failure
But then you're going to look at a decreased
CO2 level so CO2 is another test that you would see in a comprehensive metabolic
panel um, and and then you'd also look at LDH which is a typically the
comprehensive metabolic panel, but LDH is another thing if your person has congestive heart failure
um LDH can be elevated as well
um
Same thing with cardiovascular issues if you have cardiovascular issues AST can be increased
ALT can be increased with cardiovascular issues too, but you'd have an increase in CO2
and typically an increase in um, you know, uric acid with cardiovascular issues
um, but most commonly people are going to think of liver dysfunction with AST
um, plus it depends on what your current
Health issues are so if I know I have cancer or let's say I know I'm taking a medication
So again, one of the most common
causes of liver congestion, liver issues, liver dysfunction is a medication that you're taking
So if I'm taking a medication, even like a fend mendazole or an ivermectin
or tylenol so tylenol remember, statistically in america there's 15,000 people a year on average
that die of tylenol toxicity
What is it? What is what's tylenol toxicity? Have you ever heard of that?
Well, of course you don't hear of that because they're they're listed in their autopsies
diet of liver failure because it causes liver dysfunction
their STLT and alkalopossible patients went through the roof the liver just shut down
and the person died so that nobody ever said it's from tylenol but you can look up
of the anules and it is from toxicity from tylenol and over the counter medication
so medications are the number one thing that causes liver issues
because they're you're taking them in quantities that it's very difficult to detoxify
so it has been measured that different medications detoxify a different pathways in the liver
if you already have you know issues with your NAT1 pathways which a lot of meds detoxify
another different cytochrompe 450 pathways you have genetic defects on those pathways and then
you're taking these meds it's gonna be difficult to die to detoxify them and it can't overwhelm
those pathways and it can damage the liver cells and that's what liver failure is so you will see a
spike in AST and ALT and typically alkalopostasis if that is the case problem is if you're not doing
blood tests on a regular basis and you're on these medications well how do you how you're gonna know
um that's why I asked if you're gonna be on phedmentozole that you're doing a regular
comprehensive metabolic panel so we can keep an eye on things so we're not seeing any
spike plus you could have an allergic reaction to a medication that can cause liver failure
so we get more complicated so you want to keep an eye on these you don't do these blood tests
just for no reason you do these blood tests so we can see if there's damage if the liver is being
compromised in any way so those are the things that you look at with AST elevated you compare them
with like any blood test any specific individual marker you compare it with other markers to get
differential diagnosis and then you use other tests as well based upon the clues that you get
from your blood work to give you data to dig deeper to figure out the reason why you're always
looking for the reason why and to me it's a very shameful thing when I see people's blood work
and it was ordered by their their doctor and they never went even the doctor never went over it so
it's why do you order it then I don't get it so but that's another problem okay questions on the
chat have you heard of personalized peptide therapy using RGCC reported one company doing this
is neo-7 ever heard of them well there's a lot of companies that are using peptides and doing
personal peptide therapy my concern to address this of assume the past is that one concern that you
have to have with peptides is is the possibility of them stimulating growth most peptide therapy that's
the whole purpose of peptide therapy is growth they're trying to stimulate cell reproduction for cell
healing that's where all the money in peptide therapy is is it's used very widely in athletics it's used
widely in people try to heal from injuries and things so yeah I'm all for new types of therapy I've
just been careful with peptides because of the fear of stimulating growth so that one but anything
that can be proven that it can help with cancer we need to be open to next question when I had
cavitation surgery they sent in bone and found that I had a parasite no one ever gave me anything to
kill it so I finally decided to run the six hour parasite right frequency today could this make me
incredibly tired today um yes yeah yeah so if you run a kill program so if you're running a kill
program on the right then what's a kill program well kill program is anything more pathogen so you're
running a viral program well not usually a viral program but bacteria or parasite fungus things
like that if you're ready to kill program especially it's even worse if you're ready to grab negative
bacteria like live disease but if you're on a kill program I tell you the right forks and it will
kill these things and when single cell organisms are killed so there's parasites that are multicell
organisms parasites like worms and but most parasites that are going to be like in your mouth
then things like that are going to be single cell parasites and when you kill single cell organisms
you're going to liberate a lot of endotoxins meaning waste because it just it causes cell lysis the cell
the organism just basically explodes and just makes a mess from a microscopic sense and then your
body's got to get rid of those things and they have to detoxify through your kidneys and liver and
you can overwhelm your kidneys and liver and then you feel yucky so yes you feel that's what a
hurt cyber reaction is is when your liver pathways are overwhelmed and you just feel exhausted so
it's kind of your body's way to kind of shut you down and slow you down your parasite
the next are hypersimulated try to get rid of this stuff and you just need to go rest and put a hot
pack over your liver to help decrease the viscosity of your bile to help bile flow use a casserole pack
over your liver do a coffee edema all those things would be helpful in this kind of scenario
it's time for me to run another comprehensive metabolic panel for my
Joe Tippen's protocol but I've been sick since Friday with an upper respiratory gunk
I've managed to avoid antibiotics and I'm getting better but still weak I'm assuming this illness will
potentially throw off some of the numbers so I'm putting it off going in for the draw how long should
I wait is like the day after I resumed normal daily activities okay or should this should I give
this more time to get it more meaningful results no I think you should do it when you're sick so
why would I do it when you're sick okay if you have a bacterial infection or a viral infection
we'll be able to get a fairly good discernment if you run this test so if you have a bacterial infection
or a viral infection it should not affect your again why am I asking
for a complete metabolic panel comprehensive metabolic panel when a person is doing the
Joe Tippen's protocol it's this question right here what does it mean when my AST is elevated
so if I'm using Ben Mendezol that's the Joe Tippen's protocol I'm using Ben Mendezol it has the
potential of congested my liver how would I know that because I'm going to run a comprehensive
metabolic panel and I'm going to see an elevation of my AST, ALT and alkaline phosphatase so I
better calm down on my Joe Tippen's protocol maybe I'm going to pause it for a little bit it infection
won't do that so don't not get this test done when you have an infection you have respiratory
upper respiratory infection that's not going to affect your AST and ALT in an alkaline phosphatase
and if you do it when you have the infection we're going to get a clue because other thing that's
done hopefully you're not just doing a complete metabolic panel you're doing a CDC with differential
so if you're doing a CDC with differential we'll be able to see if you have an infection most likely
if it's a really nasty infection your white blood cell count will be elevated and then when we
look at the differential of the white blood cell count we'll be able to see are the lymphocytes
elevated oh it's probably a viral infection so it'll give you clues to okay then treat it as a
viral infection maybe run the the right viral program on it or if is your lymphocytes actually
suppressed but your neutrophils are are elevated then it's probably a bacterial infection then run
the bacterial programs and maybe take some specific supplements like accommodation things that
would be good for bacteria so it can be beneficial to get the test done with your ill it's not going
to your illness if it's an infection it's not going to affect the liver numbers so make sure you get a
CMP at a CDC with differential so we can get a better idea of what's going on in your lungs so you'll
be able to better treat that next question my genes have shown shown problems with glutathione
production should I be measuring glutathione in my labs to see if this is a factor why am I not
just supplementing glutathione to help with this so many cancer patients that we when we look at your
genetics you have GST GLP a whole bunch of different glutathione G defects that's not uncommon
well then why don't we give cancer patients glutathione support okay so we have to step back again
so what is glutathione do so glutathione is your primary intracellular antioxidant so glutathione is
an antioxidant so it helps get rid of oxidizing agents inside the cell so that if I have deficiencies
of glutathione in my cell that could be actually be a player in why I don't get rid of oxidizing agents
well poisons toxins and they remain in the cell and they can end up causing cancer so
glutathione deficiencies can actually be a part of the cause of cancer yes well then why don't we all
start taking glutathione because once you have cancer so once you have cancer so these cells are
rapidly replicating they're rapidly replicating cells that are rapidly replicating and these rapidly
replicating cells are not really healthy cells not all together healthy they're able to live but they're
not really healthy they don't have healthy mitochondria and that's where you make glutathione so you make
glutathione through the metabolic pathways in the transliferation system of genes that you
create glutathione in order to spew it into the intracellular space the cytoplasm where it helps
get rid of pathogens it helps get rid of oxidizing agents but kids are cells because of their
rapid replication their mitochondria are not nearly as healthy they're not producing enough glutathione
so they're at this level of self-tox that is near the level of what's called lethal death of the cell
so if a cell gets too toxic meaning it's the the oxidative stress because there's oxidizing agents
in their toxins that are in there if the oxidizing agents become too great in number if the oxidative
stress of a cell gets too high it destroys the cell and kills the cell and the cell dies
your mitochondria prevents that so your mitochondria in the cell are producing glutathione producing
superoxidist retase producing catalysts always oxidizing agents that are helping in redox reactions to
get rid of oxidizing agents so these anti oxidizing agents are getting rid of oxidizing agents keeping
the cell alive keeping the cell healthy now cancer cells because of their rapid replication are not
producing enough of this so they're very close to that threshold so if you can put it on a graph
there's a there is a point that you cross that the cell is going to die so cancer cells are close to
that threshold of lethal death healthy cells are farther down you know are more healthy that's why
they're called healthy cells they're making more glutathione even if you have genetic defects you're
still making glutathione so if you take glutathione as a cancer patient you could be supplying that which
cancer cells need to stay alive so remember most alternative therapies to kill cancer are oxidizing
their oxidative all standards of care therapies to kill cancer work because they're oxidative if you
give more poison to the body you're going to cause more oxidizing oxidative stress if you give
radiation to the body radiation is highly oxidative that's how it kills cells because of the it's it's
based it you can hit a healthy cell that's making really good mitochondria that are really healthy
that are making a lot of glutathione catalyzed superoxidides with taste you could hit that with radiation
you can kill a healthy cell because you'll cause so much oxidative stress that even the cell that's
making all these antioxidants can't handle it and the cell dies through cell lysis it's just the cell
breaks down it dies that's what radiation could do to a healthy cell well they're dosing the
radiation so they're trying not to do that to healthy cells though you can't do that perfectly so
you're going to kill healthy cells but they know that cancer cells will die first why because they're
closer to that lethal dose they're closer to that threshold of death now if you are going to go take a
whole bunch of glutathione and antioxidants what are you doing you're you're kind of helping
cancer cells stay alive and we don't want to do that so in general it's not for everybody because
sometimes we do use some antioxidants sometimes we even use glutathione with a cancer patient
but it's rare honestly so in general if we can make generalizations with cancer cancer patients people
who already have a diagnosis cancer should not be taking antioxidants now if you're in remission
and you're doing well then that's kind of off the table but if your cancer is you know aggressive
and growing you just got diagnosed and you're in the middle of other care you don't want to be if
you take antioxidants you're basically negating the effects of the oxidative therapy that you're
trying to do whether it's alternative or whether it's standards of care so that's why your oncologist
will tell you do not take antioxidants when you're doing chemotherapy okay I agree with them
you shouldn't I don't think it should take antioxidants ever unless they specifically test for you
but so you you do need to be careful you know you know a cancer patient would do things differently
than a non-cancer patient so remember that it's you know it depends on what type of morbidity
you're dealing with and how you would do that not just based upon your genes
the long answer for that question sorry but um hopefully that helps explain it any other
questions I thought a peptide was just an amino acid it is a peptide is an amino acid so a building block
a protein yeah yeah yeah yes so a peptide is a portion is so a peptide is a a combination of
amino acids so a peptide is a portion of a protein so a whole protein is named you know whatever protein
let's use gluten as an example glee added is the protein in gluten so glee added is a very
long chain protein and then a peptide of that is a portion of that say 15 amino acids long or 25
amino acids long that's a peptide of glee added so a peptide but peptides are active in the body the
peptides that are being used in peptide therapy are mainly for building up tissue and helping
stimulate that building up in growth of tissue it's a very unique peptide so a peptide of glee added
go back to gluten as an example so a peptide of glee added is a portion of the glee added protein and
it is it is a it looks like a certain a peptide of glee added maybe similar to a peptide of a different
protein but it's unique and it uniquely can affect the body that's why when you do a a food sensitivity
test for for glee added you just don't want to do just glad you glee add you want to do the most
kind of peptides of glee added as well that's that's why I recommend the Syrex test if you're
going to do a food sensitivity test because it tests for the peptides of that thing so different peptides
of different proteins act on the body in different ways that's the whole idea of peptide therapy
so in all this experimenting and all this your research this certain peptide you know xyz is used to
help stimulate growth of you know of joint capsule tissue so it can really help when you
injected in the knee of somebody who's got a damaged joint capsule or they're not making enough
joint joint fluid then you know you use peptide therapy to stimulate joint capsule cell
production and it can help stimulate its own fluid and you can prevent this person having to have
knee replacement surgery so yes peptides are parts of proteins to stimulate certain
action in the body and the reason why I kind of shyed away from them for cancer is that most people
the most clinics that have done peptide therapy for cancer there's never been any remarkable
results with it and there are clinics that are really into peptide therapy for
they're just clinics that are really super into peptide therapy so they're doing a lot of injectable
peptides 99% of the time it's on athletes or people trying to help with joint erosion or
arthritis or trying to prevent you know joint replacement therapy etc so if they're they're mainly
for stimulating growth and then when you carry it to the next thing well this will be good for
cancer too because this is so good for this person that brought back their health and everything it's
just kind of like well glutathione has really helped this person with Lyme disease and oh my gosh
it just really turned them around so when my sister has cancer so I'm gonna give tell her to take
glutathione too what works with one morbidity doesn't work with necessarily doesn't cross that line
now I know there's people that are doing research on that and I'm still waiting for more data come
out on that and so I'm really on the fence with peptide therapy I don't want to do anything that could
possibly do the wrong thing so can I use the hammer bulb on a program that calls for the spiral bulb
so when you're using the true right lots of times it'll show up picture and then it'll even have
some data use the double bubble or use the spiral bulb for this or use this you can just ignore that
for the most part so any bulb program any plasma program that would be a program that you're using the
bulb for you can use any bulb now it is true that certain bulbs will give off you know more energy
no like true it doesn't have the bubble the double bubble anymore they have the tornado bulb tube
which does have more gas in it than just the hammer tube but I don't think you need to buy another tube
tube is not gonna make that much of a difference you know now true right really only has
those two and then they have the one that you stand up like on a table for more distance
when Mike had true right he had lots of different bulbs and you know he's big into selling different bulbs
I don't think it made enough difference to have all those different bulbs the more I mean for a
technical standpoint for a quantum physics standpoint the more gas you have on the tube that you're
excited the more the more treatment that you're gonna get but again there's a there's a balance there and
how you know how much more how much should I you know is it worth getting a different bulb or not
we are actually having our own tornado bulbs made that are larger than true rice tornado bulbs
we're calling them the magna magna bulb we haven't actually have it up on our store but I don't
I'm just getting two of them in this week and I have one that's called for I don't think it's necessary
we're not gonna certainly be pushing it but we're calling it a daytime bulb because it will
put out more energy than than the hammer bulb well um okay there's some questions here
so you to answer that you could use the hammer bulb on any of the mobile programs it doesn't sound
like the peptides are anything more than a vehicle to deliver custom testments okay I'll have to
look into that custom develop meds and have tested as lethal for you for your individual cancer
which is where the RGCC testing comes from so RGCC has tested your blood and they're coming up with
their assessment on what would be the best you know what would be some different viable protocols for
a person so they might give you a whole bunch of different viable protocols including even different
chemotherapies which in their opinion might work for a person and uh so I have it I haven't we don't
do the RGCC test so I don't look at them very often the less a person has one of they want me to go
over with them but I'm certainly not a specialist in RGCC testing the other question all right well
thank you guys for being out we're praying for all of you when we come at your prayers for us
and thank you so much and we'll see you guys next week bye bye